me that's good are we good holy [ __ ] hi
hey Simon I'm being drafted in to be a
bartender for today what is a favorite
go to view anything with like herbs so
like fresh ginger I love all of these
things right I do like rum I do like
tequila and whiskey
I need having a good day or a bad day I
typically don't really go for the sweet
cocktail if you have tequila I'm sold
I will drink it maybe I will drink way
too many but tequila is gin and tonics
and I like tiki drinks classic gentleman
though what does mine say about me
party fiery anything else on the table
at ninety years old my favorite thing
about really good cocktails are they
almost remind you of medicine in a way
like a good salver like setting on
Newsline I love those big eyes you try
and cut these blue
[Music]
smells like spring time this is what you
drink when you can afford a boat yes I
agree that smells like us I can't I got
a good classifier yeah oh it looks so
nice that color then you're just gonna
dunk your head in then and drink the
whole thing like think so I'm actually
starting to salivate a little bit it's
kind of like a Pavlovian experience Oh
smells so good
Oh God it does look healthy with those
cucumber sticks in there oh gosh this
taste that's mixed summer
this may be a date I'm drinking for you
yeah though this feels definitely like
the Sun is beating down it's so
refreshing oh my god oh my god oh wow
what and nothing but quality for these
so it has like a citrusy start but then
it has a creamy finish but you can still
taste the whiskey yeah which is that I
don't know how you did it's not like
overpoweringly sweet because of water
melons still like put a lot of like
water in it I think I think this is my
favorite in chronium all-time which is
crazy because I've never had one with
tequila or mascot feel like yeah no it's
really cool that this drink takes you
like out of this world like I feel like
I'm not at a bar like I'm at you know
some holiday vacation drinking this nice
drink and it's so smooth and calming and
I just I don't know I feel at peace
maybe it's the Keela talking but your
wizard sir you are a wizard you're a
warlock back there you feel so special
and pampered you have like a drink
that's catered just for you and um I die
lucky speechless ooh I love it I am
already a little to drink at noon No